yes indeed so so in fact we believe that
we tribute internally to vision most of
our understanding of the space around us
but a lot of it happens because of an
auditory reconstruction that is linked
to the to the visual record instruction
and this process begins as early as a
new one who will turn their head towards
the sound of the mothers who is looking
for the face now in experiments in which
you present a subject in darkness with
the flash and a click of sound coming
from the same place and you ask them
okay please point to the place where
that happened if you move away this
auditory source of the click and the and
the flash but they still happen
simultaneously but in a different place
the person still perceives them as being
a single source as being a single object
and they will point to a to a point in
between the the flash and the and the
sound of the click which is roughly
one-third of this you know towards the
towards the light and two-thirds towards
the click meaning that internally the
brain is using both the evidence from
hearing as well as the aliens from
vision to try to reconstruct the
location of that of that particular
event and it's roughly waiting vision
twice as much as hearing but this is you
know relatively surprising we would
think that actually with we see the
plate precise place where things happen
and we sort of here you know something
very broad but but it is not so our
hearing acutely helps us to have a very
detailed imagery of the world and again
coming back to my previous point this is
surprising because the amount of primary
sensory receptors that are used for
hearing is so much more
than the ones that are useful for vision
that there is a substantial amount of
information processing that the nervous
system devotes too coercing this
information out of the auditory stream